[Music]
you know we live in a world of wonders
high-tech gizmos that boggle the
imagination we enjoy every single day I
mean devices that have more complexity
and more technology condensed into them
than $60,000,000 supercomputers had 40
years ago or something we get to enjoy
every day the supercomputers of
yesteryear are in everybody's hands you
know a young person with a cell phone in
Africa has better communications
technology than the US President had 25
years ago so there's no doubt these are
magnificent machines that we use to
extend the boundaries of our thinking
and of our reach nonetheless people have
this problem with technology is they
think it's somehow unnatural enter Kevin
Kelley Kevin Kelley's but what
technology wants introduces the concept
of annek Technium he calls the Technium
aggregate of all of our technology he
calls it actually the seventh kingdom of
life
he says the Technium is self-organizing
it has wants and needs and is subject to
evolutionary forces he literally says
that evolution is playing out through
the evolution of technology technology
is birthed out of the human mind if you
were able to time-lapse reality you
would see our thoughts spill over into
the world in the form of technology we
erect matter in accordance with our will
we reorganize the physical materials of
reality and turn them into objects of
higher organization and we give them
transcendent qualities I mean today we
have a device made of plastic and metal
that sends our thoughts traveling
lightly across oceans of sky I mean the
fact that I can comment along with
somebody and have what amber case refers
to is technologically mediated telepathy
mind-to-mind communication is not just
astonishing but also according to Kevin
Kelly's idea proof of the flowering of
new possibilities proof that technology
is a part of us it's made of atoms it's
natural it sits on a key
between the Bourne and the maid
Buckminster Fuller says start with the
universe the earth one single system an
integrated system we are of nature
anything that is birthed out of us is
birth out of nature so it's all good
nothing to worry about
[Music]